welcome to this course on the practical
aspects of deep learning as now you've
learned how to implement a neural
network in this week you learn the
practical aspects of how to make your
neural network work well ranging from
things like hyper parameter tuning to
how to set of your data - how to make
sure your optimization algorithm runs
quickly so you get your learning
algorithm to learn in a reasonable time
in this first we will first talk about
how the cellular machine learning
problem they will talk about
regularization and we'll talk about some
tricks for making sure your neural
network implementation is correct with
that let's get started making good
choices in how you set up your training
development and test sets can make a
huge difference in helping you quickly
find a good high performance your
network when training on your network
you have to make a lot of decisions such
as how many layers with your new network
have and how many hidden units do you
want each layer to have and what's the
learning rate and what are the
activation functions you want to use for
the different layers when you're
starting on a new application is almost
impossible to correctly guess the right
values for all of these and for other
high performance a choices on your first
attempt so in practice applying machine
learning is a highly iterative process
in which you often start with an idea
such as you want to build a new network
of a certain number of layers a certain
number of units may be on certain data
set and so on and then you just have the
code up in trying it by running your
code you run an experiment on the get
back a result that tells you how well
this particular network or this fluid
configuration works and based on the
outcome of you might then refine your
ideas and change your choices and maybe
keep iterating in order to try to find a
better and a better neural network today
deep learning has found great success in
a lot of areas ranging from natural
language processing to computer vision
to speech recognition to a lot of
applications on also structured data and
structured data includes everything from
advertisement to
websearch which isn't just internet
search engines is also for example
shopping websites or really any website
that wants to deliver great search
results when you enter terms into the
search bar
- computer security - logistics such as
figuring out where to send drivers to
pick up and drop off things - many more
so what I've seen is that sometimes a
researcher with a lot of experience in
NLP might enter you know might try to do
something in computer vision or maybe a
researcher with a lot of experience in
speech recognition might you know jump
in and try to do something on
advertising or someone from security
might want to jump and do something on
logistics and what I've seen is that
intuitions from one domain or from one
application area often do not transfer
to other application areas and the best
choices may depend on the amount of data
you have the number of input features
you have your computer configuration and
whether you're training on GPUs or CPUs
and it's so exactly what configuration
of GPUs and CPUs and many other things
so for a lot of applications I think is
almost impossible even very experienced
deep learning people find it almost
impossible to correctly guess the best
choice of hyper parameters the very
first time and so today apply deep
learning is a very iterative process
where you just have to go around this
cycle many times to hopefully find a
good choice of network for your
application so one of the things they'll
determine how quickly you can make
progress is how efficiently you can go
around the cycle and setting up your
data sets well in terms of your train
development and test sets can meet you
much more efficient at that so if this
is your training data let's draw that as
a big box then traditionally you might
take all the data you have and carve off
some portion of it to be your training
set some portion of it to be your
hold out draws validation sets and this
is sometimes also called the development
set and for brevity I'm just going to
call this the dev set but all of these
terms being roughly the same thing and
then you might carve out some final
portion of it to be your test set and so
the work though is that you keep on
training algorithms on your training
sites and use your dev set or your hold
on trial validation set to see which of
many different models performs best on
your dev set and then after having done
this long enough when you have a final
model do you want to evaluate you can
take the best model you have found and
evaluate it on your test set in order to
get a unbiased estimate of how well your
algorithm is doing so in the previous
era of machine learning it was common
practice to take all your data and split
it according to maybe a 70/30 percent um
in terms of a people often talked about
the 70/30 train tested if you don't have
an explicit dev set or maybe you know a
60 20 20 percent split now in terms of
60 percent trained 20% dev and 20
percent test
and several years ago this was widely
considered best practice in machine
learning if you have you know maybe 100
examples in total or maybe a thousand
examples in total maybe after you know
10,000 examples these sorts of ratios
were perfectly reasonable rules of thumb
but in the modern Big Data error where
for example you might have a million
examples in total then the trend is that
you're Devin 10 sets have been becoming
a much smaller percentage of the total
because remember the goal of the dev
sets that the development set is that
you're going to test different Avram's
on it and see whichever works better so
the death set just needs to be big
enough for you to evaluate say two
different algorithm courses or ten
different averages and quickly decide
which one is doing better and you might
not need a whole 20 percent of your day
for that so for example we have a
million chin examples you might decide
that just having ten thousand examples
in your death set is more than enough to
evaluate you know which one or two
algorithms does better and in a similar
vein the main goal of your test set is
given your final classifier to give you
a pretty confident estimate of how well
it's doing and again if you have a
million examples maybe you might decide
that 10,000 examples is more than enough
in order to evaluate a single qualifier
and give you a good estimate of how well
it's doing so in this example where you
have a million examples if you need just
10,000 for your Devon 10,000 for your
test your ratio would be more like
10,000 is 1% of 1 million so you have
98% trained 1% death 1% yes and I've
also seen applications where if you have
even more than million examples you
might end up with you know 99.5% trained
and 0.25 percent death 0.25 percent test
or maybe a 0.4 percent deaf 0.1 percent
test so just a recap when setting up
your machine learning problem more often
set up into a trained F and test sets
and if you have a relatively small data
set these traditional ratios might be
okay but if you have a much larger data
set is also fine to set your Devon test
sets to be much smaller than you know
20% or even want to 10% of your data
will give more specific guidelines on
the sizes of Devon test sets later in
this specialization one other trend
we're seeing in the era of modern deep
learning is that more and more people
train on mismatched training test
distributions let's say you're building
an app that lets users upload than all
the pictures and your goal is to find
pictures of cats in order to show your
users maybe all your users in canvas
maybe your training set comes from cat
pictures downloaded off the internet of
then your Devon headset
might comprise cat pictures from users
using our app
Samira training centers while the
pictures traveled off the internet but
the Devin testers are pictures uploaded
by users
turns out of all the web pages have very
high resolution very professional very
nicely framed pictures of cats but maybe
your users are uploading you know
blurrier lower res images just taken
with a cell phone camera in a more
casual condition and so these two
distributions of data may be different
the rule of thumb might encourage you to
follow in this case is to make sure that
deep dev and test sets come from the
same distribution we'll see more about
this particular guideline as well but
because you will be using the death set
you value a lot of different models and
trying really hard to improve
performance on a death set is nice if
your death set comes from the same
distribution as your test set but
because deep learning algorithms are
such a huge hunger for training data one
trend I'm seeing is that you might use
all sorts of creative tactics such as
crawling webpages in order to acquire a
much bigger training set than you would
otherwise have even if part of the cause
of that is then that your training set
data might not come from the same
distribution as your dev and test set
but you find that so long as you follow
this rule of thumb that progress in your
machine learning algorithm will be
faster and I'll give a more detailed
explanation for this tutorial some dates
and descritization as well finally it
might be okay to not have a test set
remember to go of the test set is to
give you a unbiased estimate of the
performance of your final network of the
network that you selected but you don't
need that unbiased estimate then it
might be okay to not have a test set so
what you do if you have only a death
step and all the test size is you
trained on the training set and then you
try different model architectures
evaluate them on the death set and then
use that to iterate and try to get to a
good model because you fit today to the
dev set there's no long surgeon unbiased
estimate of performance but if you don't
need one that might be perfectly fine
in the machine learning world when you
have just a train on a deaf set but no
separate test set
most people will call this the training
set and they will call the death set the
test set but what they actually end up
doing is using the test set as a holdout
cross-validation Center which maybe
isn't completely a great use of
terminology because they're then
overfitting to the chip set so when the
team tells you that they have only a
train and a test set you know I would
just be cautious and think do they
really have a trade deficits because
they're overfitting to the test set
culturally it might be difficult to
change some of these teams terminology
and get them to call it a train death
sets rather than train test set even
though I think calling it a train and
development set would be more correct
terminology and this is actually okay
practice if you don't need a completely
unbiased estimate of the performance of
your algorithm so having set up a train
death and test set to allow you to
iterate more quickly it will also allow
you to more efficiently measure that
bias and variance of your algorithm so
they can more efficiently select ways to
improve your algorithm let's start to
talk about that in the next video